for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university com thank you and enjoy now
that we've talked about compound it's
important that we get into how to name
them because there are just so many
compounds that exist and we need to have
a systematic way of naming them because
we need to be able to look at a chemical
formula and say okay that compound has
this name and we also need to be able to
look at a certain name and recognize
that it has a certain formula right and
we need to be systematic about it but
before we can actually learn that
process that I view things that we have
to have memorized okay so we'll start
off with the monatomic ions specifically
we'll start off with the monatomic
cations now monatomic means one atom
cations positive charge okay so we'll
see here we've got this first the first
view here from H down to CS those are
all of the group 1 elements right and
they all form a plus one charge right
and we know that they form a plus one
charge because they want to reach that
noble gas configuration right they have
one extra electron that if they lose
boom noble gas configuration okay except
hydrogen it loses that electron then it
has no electrons at all okay in addition
ag+ a transition metal forms a plus one
I on okay so that is silver ion then
we've got the mg all the way to be a two
plus those in the group 2a elements
right and we already know that they form
plus two charges because it's lose two
electrons to regional what gas
configuration in addition to them zinc
and cadmium both form plus two ions and
then we've got aluminum back down here
group 3 a element that forms a plus 3i
on now as far as their names go their
names are just the same as the actual
element name so h plus is hydrogen Zn
plus oh sorry ZN too
us is zinc mg 2 plus is magnesium but
then the question comes if the cations
have the same name as the element how do
we distinguish them from a neutral
element right what makes an a different
from na plus is if na is sodium then why
is na plus also sodium well if you're
talking about just na its sodium right
sodium metal and every talking about na
plus you're talking about sodium ion so
you'd add an eye on after it right now
when it comes to actually naming or not
you're going to drop the word I on but
we'll see how that works later okay but
with these cations it's just their name
next up is the monatomic anions right so
monatomic again one atom anions negative
charge okay so we've got these these
first few here have a minus one charge
hydrogen if it gains an electron it
becomes H minus Rises 0 minus one charge
then we'll notice here fluorine to
iodine those are the halogens right they
are the group 7a elements okay and then
we've got the group 6-8 here forming
minus two ions right and this is all
because that's how many electrons right
they have to gain in order to regional
gas configuration the halogens gain one
they have a noble gas configuration
group six elements or group six a gain
two electrons to form the noble gas
configuration then group 5 a they gained
three to form the electro excuse me the
noble gas configuration now on well
you'll notice as far as the names go is
they have the the element name followed
by the ending I'd right they end in ID
and so I'd is the ending associated with
these anions right so for instance
hydrogen is hydride right so you drop
the vo gin and replace it with ID right
so give the root of the element named
plus the ending I'd so you should
memorize all these right iodine becomes
iodide night nitrogen becomes nitride so
on and so far so you should memorize all
of these ok
next up a little bit more confusing now
I don't know about confusing but a
little bit tougher metals that form more
than one monatomic ion so some metal
specific specifically the transition
metals right so we have the transition
elements here they form more than just
one I on now metals form cations so
that's pretty pretty much the case with
all of these but if they form more than
one eye on then we can't just call it
like we like we did over here with them
simple monatomic cations because sodium
since it just forms one eye on the ion
na plus one we could just call it sodium
ion right but what happens when we have
these elements that form more than one
eye on ok so let's do with chromium
chromium we can have CR 2 plus in which
case that would be called chromium too
ok where the two is Roman numerals in
parentheses ok we have CR three plus
that's another eye on that chromium can
form and that'll be chromium parenthesis
Roman numeral three so chromium 3 ok now
these are the systematic names in this
column here ok these are the systematic
names and over here each of the common
names ok the common names are used much
as much less frequently than in the past
but what you'll notice is that for
example with chromium CR 2 plus it's
called chromis and CR 3 plus is called
chromic okay now what's what's basically
happening is that we'll see what the
others here that we have these endings
us and it us sick sick sick and the
reason for that or sign I don't not
going to say the reason for that will
notice though is that the charge of the
lower magnitude ends in 0 us and the
charge of the higher magnitude ends in
it I see ok so if we look at if we look
at
let's see copper right copper forms CU
plus one which is called copper one the
systematic naming right and that would
be called cuprous okay it also forms a
CU plus two right which is called copper
to all right which is but that's called
cupric because that too is a higher
magnitude than one okay now I like the
systematic naming more because of how
explicit it is with with the name right
whatever the magnitude of the charge is
that's what the that's the number that
goes in the Roman numerals for instance
tin for is SN 2 SN 4 plus right and then
10 2 is SN 2 plus right and these common
names again you could just memorize them
the one once you have the memorized it's
fairly simple to keep in mind that the
only the lower magnitude of charge and
to know us the higher magnitude ends in
icy or ick but yeah it really just takes
memorizing those right so you have to be
able to recognize these ions by their
names and these names you have to be
able to associate them with their ions
ok now i wrote monatomic up here right
one of them is kind of exception here
and that is this guy right here this hg2
2 plus right that's called mercury one
and the reason why is because if you
think about it it's got to to Mercury's
there and as a total it has a plus two
charge so this isn't really monatomic
it's got to Mercury's there and the
overall charge is plus two so you could
think about each one having a plus one
charge hence mercury one so that's a
little bit of a weird case there ok but
the rest you should be able to figure
out if you just keep in mind the charge
and the systematic name and the idea
that us is the lower magnitude and it
goes the higher magnitude a lot of
people are actually moving away from
using the common names because they're
not as explicit as a systematic names ok
so that's the monatomic ions we also
have to know the polyatomic ions now
polyatomic means many atoms right so
these are ions that have many atoms
than them okay now most of them are our
anions right just these two up here NH 4
plus + h three o plus our cations the
rest are anions okay NH 4 plus is called
ammonium h3o plus excuse me is called
hydronium and the rest have minus
charges okay now really when it comes to
these you just have to memorize them you
have to know what's what okay like if I
say what's SC n minus if they know
that's IO cyanate if I say what's clo 4
minus that's perchlorate you if they
know that so I would encourage you to
pause it right these down or maybe you
already have this table somewhere but
the idea is that you just need to
memorize this ok it's nothing nothing
fun about it it just you got to know
these ok now there is something to keep
in mind though is that there are a lot
of these that have multiple oxygens in
them or at least one oxygen in them
often have different variations of them
in them based on the number of oxygens
they have that might have been extremely
confusing now that I've said that but
what I'm trying to say is like there are
groups like this for instance let's just
look at these right here ok if we have
CL 0 minus cielo 2-0 3-0 4 minus their
kind of a family ok and this these are
examples of a family of ox 0 anions oxxo
anions oxxo referring to the idea that
they have oxygens anions pours negative
charge ok so when you're looking at
these with the way I what will helps me
remember them is that I just look at the
one that ends in eight so CLO 3-1 is
chlorate ok so what I do is I always
remember that eight things that end in
eight always have one more oxygen than
the thing that ends in aight so if I
know that chlorate is CLO 3-1 that means
it has to be CLO 2-1 and that's what we
find here chlorite has a CLO 2-1 right
so yeah
so aight always has one less oxygen than
eight okay also now that there's there's
also hypo and then ight and then / that
ends in eight so / if something has the
the prefix / then and ends up ending an
eight that means it has one more oxygen
than whatever is eight so after chlorite
if Gloria has three oxygens perchlorate
has four and that's what we notice in
this table here perchlorate has four
oxygens okay and then the one that has
the the prefix hypo and ends in aight
that has one less oxygen than aight
right so chlorite had cielo 2-1
hypochlorite has one less CL 0 minus 1
so that's a way to sort of help you
remember these things but ultimately
what you'll have to do is just memorize
them one other thing that I do want to
mention is that some of them have two
names right like like this guy right
here hco3 minus one that is called that
is hydrogen carbonate but it's also
called bicarbonate okay and up here hso
four minus that is hydrogen sulfate but
it can also be called by sulfate and so
this is something that that I sort of
learned when studying these is that just
kind of look at similarities and
recognize the differences that kind of
helps me at least remember them at a
certain point though you will have used
them so much that you'll just know them
okay but yeah do what you guys you to
memorize these last thing you got to
know is the numerical prefixes these are
the Greek numerical prefixes that
basically tell you that correspond to a
certain number if you've got one one is
mono to is die three is trying like a
tricycle tricycle has three wheels for
is tetra five is Penta like a Pentagon
if your study giant geometry right hexa
hexagon octa octagon deca tech a decade
right
here's a wait what does that hexagon
that I'm drawing anyway the point is
that you should know these these these
Greek numerical prefixes right if
something says it has naana in it that
means it's referring to 9 of something
okay so we should have these memorized
before we start naming anything I kind
of want to put check marks next to these
others because it's just bothering it
they're not there okay anyway I hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying